um well I see you vote everyone know you
know my angst about his presentation um
you know I come to especially after
being at the first couple of days of the
Institute um I came to my you know
preparing my presentation with kind of a
sense of schizophrenia if not multiple
personality disorder if you would look
at my brief you see that I am speaking I
am supposed to be speaking largely
within discipline i am a literature
scholar all 20 comment a little bit more
what that means to me these days and on
the other hand after 12 years of being
either associate director or the first
post 911 director and the first
literature specialist director of the
herman institute since the harriman
money was given in the early 1980s i
have a lot of baggage on the things that
have been discussed and so I've been
trying desperately to figure out how I
could I could get in everything and I'm
going to cheat a bit i'm going to try to
make emma grace be the thread that runs
throughout my presentation but i also
want to in some ways incorporate my
experience having to deal as a regional
Institute Director with the period not
just post-soviet but post 911 and also
with the tensions of being in Columbia
School of International and public
affairs and imbalance in regions
disciplines practice policy theory
humanities and Social Sciences on a
day-to-day basis so I'm I'll tell you
what this is my grid first of all um
first of all I'm going to be drawing
largely on not just my experience well
my experience is one of my bullet points
and I'm going to talk a little bit more
about that in a second but also I I was
charged on largely because Marshall Sean
Manette that
although he was still very much with us
was really not feeling up to writing
with reading the history of the
beginning of the Harriman Institute for
the 250th anniversary book for Columbia
University which for those of you have
seen it's quite massive it's called
living legacies and then we were
celebrating our 60th anniversary at the
Harriman Institute so this little
booklet and I don't know if they're
enough of them that Lance to be willing
to give them out to you but it reprints
my article on the beginnings of the
heroin institute some of which you've
heard from David Angermann already it
also has lovely biographies of some of
the founding and most important people
in the Harriman institute by other
important faculty members of the
Harriman Institute and including a
number of them have already been at this
Institute and then a nice touch I think
is that it has some biographies of
recent graduates of the hominids to them
and what they do now you know so again
I'm I thought it was up on the hammond
website it's not but you're welcome i
can pass it around if you want to look
at it or you can look at it during a
break and again there may be copies that
can be gotten if you're interested from
the Institute itself what was going to
be the primary subject of my remarks but
I think especially given my time
constraints is going to be slightly more
is an upcoming article of life that's
coming out ironically in a history of
Soviet literary theory and criticism
edited by afghani de blanco and going T
cut off but I got to write hammer grade
and repose for Emma cries so I'm so this
is coming out in October and i will be
using drawing on that I'm and then I am
going to be giving you some syllabi they
were already in front of you because I
thought you know knowing and having
discussed with that or for some time I'm
the goals of the Institute that seeing
syllabi that we believe are but that we
will most all but one of them has
already been used one of those videos
many times the kind of syllabus syllabi
real classes that define for us what
regional studies are in the 21st sign
Cherie so following in my steps of
footsteps of my former dean Bob McKay
I'm going to try and organize my
presentation around bullet points I
don't usually do bullet points but
probably a good idea otherwise I was
likely to ramble hopefully so first of
all first bullet point disciplinary
tensions or an issue from the very
beginnings of Soviet ology and many
studies okay I'll come back to that and
we need to be extremely careful about
distinguishing between between various
different terms and being sensitive to
the evolution of disciplinary concerns
something I think David angular is to
draw some what is taught bullet point
number two area studies in the United
States trace their beginnings and
evolution in no small part from the
exclusion or marginalization of
emigration okay point number three emma
grace then the last played a key role as
what new historicist Stephen Greenblatt
has called cultural intermediaries
between the US public and academics and
Russia and then again this is in the BK
Academy and very much beyond I wanted to
work in somehow that I played hooky and
wednesday night went to see at american
ballet theatre sir Gareth one skis a
production of the bright screen stream a
socialist realist ballet which is a
topic in and of itself what do we do
with you know the artistic
intermediaries um that have been so much
a part of the landscape of the United
States since the post world and in full
at four point number four and this is
kind of my sleazy thread that's going to
get me to the syllabi at the end we
really need to look at the significance
of emigrants as students not just as
professors and experts ok so those are
the four points I'm going to try to
address again briefly the clock is
moving very fast I was afraid I wouldn't
have enough to say of course yeah so
those of you know me laughs okay but I'm
going to situate myself for a moment
because I think that although as I think
a Russian friend of mine once sent all
americans love is biographies and how
they got into saw the girl weird you
know what that makes me represent it
first of all despite my name I am NOT an
immigrant I am married to one and in
fact all the only kind of blood I
probably don't have a Slavic although I
did have a grandfather was born in pills
but Austria and in any case um so I
actually went to but I desperately
wanted to study Russian and I couldn't
of course growing up in New Jersey and
public schools even good ones I study
French from a very early agent so I went
to college and I picked my college out
of barons college guide because I wanted
a felon college that had both one of the
best French and one of the best Russian
departments in the country would also
accept women which in 1969 was a problem
okay so i ended up at Brown University
which I was very fortunate to have ended
up there and was actually a french maid
French Russian major and also got a
master's in french at the same time on
my journal i was an undergraduate so
that's to put the comparative context
and out there and and also to point out
that i did not consider majoring in
comparative literature at the time you
know so that's one of the big evolution
but hot that's happened that more and
more although I consider myself very
much a comparative if that was not an
option I wanted to be specifically
national language departments and i'll
come back to the obsession with russian
later and I then was told in no
uncertain terms and I also work very
closely I'm kind of closet his story and
i work with Tom nice and very closely I
probably took more courses with him than
with anybody
anyone in slavic department so I
considered myself rather
multidisciplinary from the very
beginning and then I was it was told to
me over and over and over again only cuz
i could go graduate schools columbia um
and I resisted that I didn't I grew up
in New Jersey I didn't want to go to
school in New York City but nonetheless
I found myself here and a student in the
russian institute and a very much i took
courses my first year with john hazard
my only lock horse ever and with a
marker I of intellectual history where
my head at the time and and also went on
to be part of Edward all worse project
and year he didn't do Central Asia you
know and hopefully if those if he
doesn't come up in this seminar believe
he will but there's a lovely biography
of him in this book and I'd be happy to
talk more about him and then of course
when I become a faculty member at bonner
and but rock island's the barn Columbia
relationship if I got into all of those
things we'd be forever and also got my
hairline certificate before then and the
rest is history um now I'm going to go
back to why did I want to study Russian
to begin with because as I said um you
know one russian translator one-a-day
said all americans have a strange story
and I had no idea i just wanted to study
it no one day I was walking down college
and walk but she now all know very well
and I ran into my neighbor for 11 3 and
4 years old and he was in med school so
what are you doing and I said I'm
studying Russian literature here and he
said would you remember my nanny Lizzie
I said yeah sure I remember Lissie he
said you remember she was Russia and she
taught us Russian words when we were
three and four years old memories
assistant but talk about cultural
intermediaries I mean you know so in the
role hema price and I suspect behind all
of us americans love is there is some
early cultural intermediary that more or
less influenced our
or decisions to become slava's um now as
david yurman pointed out and I think I
believe his point was very heavily
indebted to to Marshall shaman who
believed in this very fervently area
studies really did not come out of the
cohort predated the Cold War and it came
out of the OSS and out of the war effort
and various different points because not
only the original faculty for instance
of the reach of the russian institute of
columbia was the original students many
of you who had had been including
Marshall Charlemagne Corey um have been
redirected to their interesting Russia
from their service in the war but it
also meant emma grace works because I as
Marshall told me the story when jury
tampering Robinson went to Washington to
form a group within OSS he was
specifically told not to use emma grace
because of their biased position
assumedly they were also considered
security risk hearts too hard to know
but that that was what he said and so
the first generation of Slavic scholars
were American because and they many of
them had come from other disciplines or
they were not Russian estes and so again
area study says we know it largely came
from the from the from the exclusion of
MCAS Ansari just jumped a bullet point
number two and jumped right over bullet
point number one so I'm going to come
back to that in a moment and I but what
I wanted to talk about before that is
the issue of disciplinary tension which
i think is something that really needs
to come up very strongly in this and
this inner Enterprise here because to my
mind it is has always been an amazed the
primary promise and the primary
challenge
studying of studies region across
disciplinary boundaries from the very
beginning it was a problem at Columbia
because it had been negotiated very very
thoroughly that every faculty member of
the five founding fathers that were
hired into Columbia had to be vetted by
the relevant disciplinary department and
they had to get hammered and this was a
big negotiation to get this to happen
and quite honestly all was not rosy from
the very beginning about the
relationships between the disciplinary
departments and the Institute there are
two of us sitting in this room who were
given opposite advice about whether to
get regional Institute's certificates by
the same faculty member in Islamic
department Carolyn back we can elaborate
on that later but it was very often that
faculty members in disciplinary
departments who would tell their PhD
candidates not to go for russian
institute certificates and to stay away
from the Institute um so the you know
even here where the program you know um
really flourished greatly and you know
we're very proud I'm very proud to be a
product of it um it there were always
tensions and if anything they became
greater over the years i think david and
Gurman talked about in the increasing
increasing territorial nature of
disciplinary disciplines and lasts for
years and that has made things even
harder all to negotiate for many reasons
so again i'm happy to talk more about
that in question and answer but i'm
going to move on from that now i just
think that we need to make distinguished
between the faculty even have trouble
finding a charm area studies is no
longer you know considered its area
studies literally is a bad name you know
so i found myself as director of
harriman referring to it as regional
studies I'm not sure I by Bob McKay's
and
national studies rubric which i don't
think is really what we do um but we
need to be very careful about
distinguishing that osmotic studies and
they're very different things and both
of them are subsumed under this
institute but slavic studies really is
the humanities and is very specifically
that which is located in slavic
departments mom and that's of course
where the migr story is going to be
much more exciting and but to give you
some ideas of about the kind of tensions
that we saw with literature in the
belknap him I don't know if he's coming
back but you can ask about Ali edge away
to master's thesis because he is a
Dostoevsky specialist in those days
we've loosened up since he could not put
his lovak department master's thesis um
on those day off ski in as his Harriman
Institute certificate essay he had to
write another essay on social Israel's
that was on to the in the days of
Simmons these days we would not do that
if you had done a verra Sunday mirsky
Dunham one of the few literature people
who was in Washington and who was you
know is part of the larger area studies
story um taught at the Harriman
Institute not in the Slovak department
which was I will be honest source of
tension and as I said graduate said
students in arts and sciences were often
discouraged from getting regional
Institute certificates now in terms of
being careful about our terms it's
important also to situate the evolution
of Slavs studies and rotate in
relationship to comparative literature
and cultural studies and if there's time
I'll combats that later I now consider
myself mostly comparative literature and
cultural historian as long as well as
being a Slav 'used and we should also
remember that slavic studies per se were
implicitly and sometimes explicitly
excluded from soviet ology for those of
you who have read
steve cohen's book Soviet ologies of
occasion literature barely figures there
except for mentions of earnest Simmons
in other words we were not part of
Soviet ology for better or worse so when
you talk about area studies you know
again we're we are the kind of the poor
younger country cousin you know out
there someplace and at the worst there
were social scientists and I won't name
names on this one who simply considered
Slavic departments to be serviced places
for social scientists teaching them
language and that was it and that was
all we did and they weren't interested
in anything else however on the brighter
side as we look to the future and that's
one of the places I want to end we need
to look more and more at exile and
diaspora studies as we look at
emigration what the Russian migr
experience which increasing number of
graduate students are now interested in
going back and looking at really
emigration in Russia and there be you
know and it was precisely in terms of
this post colonial paradigm of diaspora
studies okay so that's bullet point
number one and a little bit of bullet
point number two ok now we're bullet
point number two and I'm really glad to
speed up um now again as I pointed out
there was a reason to emigrate played a
limited or very specific role in
regional studies they were excluded from
working in Washington during the war um
and again that's what that is largely
what gave impetus to a new generation of
Americans were Soviet specialists
including founding fathers all of the
russian institute all of whom were not
Russia now then of course emma grace had
the peculiar status of being basically
the beast to be studied david Angermann
talked about the harvard refugee project
and you know the extent to which emma
grace because of the limited access to
the USSR for American scholars during
the early
it uh that was what you had you know and
you were going to talk to emma grace as
a source of information obviously this
would change over time as there was
increasing ability for American scholars
to travel to the Soviet Union and to
actually have direct contacts with
people still living in the USSR and
ultimately to have students from the
region now one place that emma grace of
course were particularly valuable was
because so few universities had on
russian studies and russian language
before the war as the as the various
different impulses that spirit the
growth of russian studies and slavic
studies in the United States happened
emma grace were greatly in demand you
know especially as little as um as
language specialists and here one thing
to bear in mind is that um the growth of
slavic studies did not happen in
isolation and I don't know David
mentioned this but of course there's an
extraordinary growth of us universities
after the war so one has to see this in
this context that it wasn't just and I
think um if you rightly pointed out an
awful lot this happened before Sputnik
so this would be praised did spur it but
again a lot of it and this has shaped
our field very greatly that literature
studies was the incredible number of
hires that were made in the 50's and
into the 60s which therefore left some
of us without jobs for a very long time
because you know there were because
departments were so large and so well
staffed but in other words emma grace
did have a place and some of us again I
already talked about Lizzy I will talk
about some of my other favorite people
so I don't know how many of you ever
knew Tatiana Roman who was actually
Gail Romans mother named short for
Romanoff as she told us what net was
great revelation to me as a beginning
language student or relatively clean
language student that her family had
married down into the Romanoff family
she was shortened her name and I she was
an absolutely wonderful I mean some of
us might Columbia remember of course the
wonderful rose Raskin I'm sure Carol and
I would be thrilled to talk more about
Nikolai Azarov who taught it both
Columbia you know and that's just a tiny
number of people who you know really
were our lifeblood of language and might
men and and what was really wonderful
that it is someone who was one of the
very few people who was able to go to
the Soviet Union gisela Russia after
basically my first year of Russia and
came back as it was much too mrs. Roman
some dismay speaking soviet russia in
other words i was swallowing all of my
endings so she couldn't tell which case
i was putting in good very deliberately
was very useful so in the Soviet Union I
was being told that my my language was
communally and here I was being told our
Soviet you know but it was good to you
know to uh to get those perspectives um
now bullet point number straight now
coming back to the post-war period we
need to remember another part of this
you know just as america emerged from
the second world wouldn't in an
enormously different place from where it
was when it went in I mean and um it was
it was it wasn't world leader but it
really wasn't going into World War two
and not only that it was it it had
received an incredible on the quest of
intellectual life from those Europeans
who were fleeing from the war and not
just Russians and it's very important to
to to see that this
Gemma phrase who came here did not come
in isolation I mean y'all are gonna talk
more about Roman jakub send to think
about the people of Rome and Jakub
stinnett when he came here noam chomsky
levy Strauss I mean in other words there
was an incredible intellectual ferment
permit going on in this country after
the war and though and and some of the
major emigration were very much part of
it um now I'm really this is supposed to
be my major topic but looking at the
clock i'm going to give it i know that
my colleagues here i have a lot to say
in a subject this afternoon so I'm going
to say relatively little about it um you
know I have taken as my examples the
obvious the jakub son in norwalk of the
two who battled the University and
public outside the two who nut broke out
of the immigrant ghetto but also um but
also always kept their commitment to
Russia studies Oh a little a little a
little sideline here one of the things
that gets left out in here is it wasn't
just Russian migr obviously and you
know and I had the great privilege of
studying with Victor terrace Brown and
we and we can first make a long list of
eastern and and of course Elizabeth
falconers father Manfred cradle to I
polish at Columbia so we have to
remember that they won't know who was
part of this slovak the role that slovak
emigrate was also gibbering the non
russian slovak literature's and cultures
and languages to the United States but
of course yakap Stan and Nabokov didn't
get along we won't go there if you want
to talk about you can do that's more but
I mean when we think about the
incredible impact that these two
scholars alone had on American
intellectual life in the post-war period
it's really rather stunning and let me
just look for a moment
walk off I mean because I'm actually
writing a book on the book right now so
I could stand a book for an awfully long
time but um Nabokov although you know
one could say he was an American writer
I personally believe he never stopped
being a Russian writer and in fact it
was precisely in the interspaces between
his Russian and his American experience
and his European expense that he he'd
well as a writer and as a person and
it's one of the reasons he's such a hot
topic right now with diaspora studies
because emigration was so much a part of
both his life and all of all of his
various different projects and I I just
can't help bringing up for many reasons
here because because if there is a
representation of the stereotypical
Russian migr in slavic studies in the
post-war period the book was timofei
mean would probably be the most
endearing and i will say that it was
reading kanina brought me back to walk
off and you know i mean there's been a
lot of talk about I mean the character
finding being based with some irony on
the book of college at Cornell marks of
tau um there's clearly a dull of the
book of himself and canoe but it is the
image of the somewhat awkward russian
migr who is ghetto wised into teaching
language as he walks away on this epic
project that nobody will ever read but
which he loves dearly and who can never
quite get the difference between a
football and soccer ball and ice and who
is relegated to teaching brother doltish
American students who really you know
although they do seem to some of them to
appreciate he's a nice guy don't really
get it and I think that you know Nabokov
and nobody better than evolved of gave
gave an image 22
the the the rather poignant situation of
many of these Russian migr who found
their way into american academia the
bulk of on the other hand is the
extraordinary success story I mean you
know because not you know he's
fabulously not just lolita even before
lolita his extraordinarily successful a
literature courses cornell which so many
people i've met so many people at this
point of taking this course you know
that even though he was his Western
literature course that most of them took
of course he works in Russian in there
and by the way I would also point out
the pinion was published in The New
Yorker you know so this is again part of
the on you know Trent you know
interpreting the Russian experience for
on the American audience was very much
what the book was all about now with the
third wave of immigrants re that's all i
can say but in a buckle but i'll never
get anyplace if i go much farther things
change some up with the third wave of
them agrees I mean obviously I was
talking primarily about the first wave
of them are grace here who came to the
United States after that as a result of
the war I have whipped over some
institutions that probably should be
mentioned but that they brought with
them or that serve them well but I think
since David adamant a lot about
institutions oh I will skip that and go
into the third way for the emma grace
and they largely felt faced the same
problems is the first wave but obviously
is the first generation of of really
soviet citizens people who have been
born in the Soviet Union
thing else the imperative of the first
wave of emigration to preserve the true
Russian culture to somebody they take it
back and to somehow find a way of
balancing preserving that true culture
with also conveying it to an American
public that was not always in their
estimation sophisticated enough to
understand it the third wave was very
much directed and much more interesting
what was going on in the Soviet Union
arm and you know again you can I can
create nice public polarities between
broadsky on the one hand who followed in
the footsteps of the block of enya
copson coming on a figure on the
American cultural scene on becoming the
poet Lord in the United States with me
winning the Nobel Prize going over into
writing essays in english and again
transcending the emigrant ghetto trying
to add to say although again broadsky
very much never left his Russian roots
behind and remained very very much
connected to the Russian migr
community as even did by the way
Baryshnikov um you know while he was out
going to Holly wait this is before sex
in the city I think but you know but but
even personal had it to me as well
thoughts until I've had was very
involved in literary projects for the
immigration on the other hand there
Solzhenitsyn who lived up through in
Vermont and tried to pretend he was in
Russia and then occasionally came out
and gave speeches you like the hoff the
notoriously hard speech in what was it
1978 which disabused Americans of their
belief that dissidents necessarily were
Democrats you know so he was a culture
on the intermediary of sorts the United
States but again dissident Americans
were hearing war on
more about the soviet union from
journalistic sources and directly from
the soviet union so that also display
emma grace became interesting um as
celebrities in the nineties because many
of the dissidents largely i mean and so
that's a no and so many of the Raiders
who got academic appointments in this
country got them because because they
had already become well known through
through their oppositionist activities
in the Soviet Union before they left um
which leads me to bullet point number
for an appraisal students those
emigrates who came who were not
celebrities were routinely advised at
Colombian I believe elsewhere no matter
what Howard exalted degree they had
achieved in the Soviet Union to go back
to graduate school in United States or
they would not get a job okay so there
was um there are a fair number of
faculty members even now I would say
your wiener ravemon here at Columbia who
you know went for her PhD at stanford
this was not actually totally new
because Alexander darlin the only
emigrate to be director of the Harriman
or the russian institute I'm actually um
did his training in the United States
you know so there have always been a
McGray students but with the third wave
of immigration we found more and more
migr students undergraduate and
graduate and I think this is a
phenomenon that has happened more and
more throughout the country and um on
the one hand this poses certain
challenges to in terms of pedagogy
because it's sometimes difficult to have
heritage speakers of Russian and non
Harris
speakers motion in the same classrooms
we are very fortunate here at Columbia
because we have a big enough program and
we have two tracks and and it works very
very well because students self-select
you know they take classes together but
a self select into the right classes and
some tensions that we used to have at
one time we don't have any more but I
want to talk about a more interesting
phenomenon than just that the extent to
which migr students are our lifeblood
not completely but part of our life like
these days and that is um with the
collapse of the Soviet Union here here
I'm speaking more about graduate courses
but not completely I have found myself
more and more learning from my students
because we have an extraordinarily
diverse number of students coming from
various different regions of the soup
former Soviet Union um and let me stop
for a second I think again this is I
think David Ingram it probably raised
this but with the collapse of the Soviet
Union regional Institute's who really
faced with what we going to do now and
one of the big big big questions was are
we going to be Russian Institute's or
are we going to cover the entire area
well Harriman I think rightly decided we
were going to do a whole area and in
fact we also totally took over Eastern
Europe to you know but that means that
um you know we have responsibility for
an extraordinary diverse area which as
Bob McKay pointed out I think rightly
gives us enormous comparative
possibilities you know and also a lot of
pedagogical challenges for those of us
who are trained primarily is Russian
asus now with all due respect my former
dean i will say i think this is a
development he may not be crazy about
these 19 anymore um he pointed out that
it was an
in fact that all of the money that went
into regional studies from Soviets
studies would filter down to the liberal
arts colleges but we're very proud to
say that Varner graduated its first
Hungarian regional studies may under
undergraduate major in its first polish
undergraduate regional studies major
this year following with this along with
some second ukrainian regional studies
ins been and following its first check
regional studies major several years ago
and one of our russian majors actually
really did all the work for a
serbo-croatian major as well you know so
this is really now this is of course an
anomaly for monitoring Columbia Columbia
actually can't offer these degrees but
the courses are obviously being taught
by Columbia graduate students and
faculty you know so again that's a
peculiarity of our institutional
structure but it also shows that even at
the undergraduate level we're getting
more students from the region who have
some knowledge they're usually
first-generation here some of them are
warm they are some point here and they
want to study and they need to study
because as I think it's been said
sometimes it's it's it sometimes if not
always it's harder to teach those who
knew something then those who know
nothing and so some of the migr some
of the migr students who come from
families where they've learned something
have to unlearn some things that
American students are just no nothing so
we can just pour stuff right into them
so that is an issue as well now I want
to talk a little bit about this course
is precisely the point of view the
students who have taken them but but I
will and and what they are meant to
accomplish and I'm going to start with
one that I've taught from us 20 years
although the first people the two first
people to teach it legacies
the Soviet Union you can have mark on
Hagen set to explain to you how many
different titles it's actually gone
through he first bought it first year it
was taught in 1992 with Rick Erickson
the economists who was originally within
director the Harriman Institute and
Marcos associate director at that time
traditionally the course has been taught
by the director and also associate
director of the Institute and this
course was put into being precisely to
deal with the issue of how do we
maintain our coherence Oh as a program
offering a certificate at the Harmon
Institute after the collapse of the
Soviet Union and this is the most recent
version of the course we just I just I
just graded it last night as a matter of
fact this semester I'm a little late
which I co-taught with Alexander Moodle
who was here yesterday so he came home
and help me co grade the course and so
the idea is that is always taught by a
humanities personal and social
scientists as well preferably it's
always it is always 0 but once or twice
has been taught by a man and a woman and
if there's time I'd love to go into
gender and area studies but you know I
doubt that we'll get there today um and
the idea of it is to have students read
almost every week things from every
major discipline in the region now
what's been fabulous about this course
has been the mix of students sometimes
frustrating sometimes fabulous it's
every graduate student getting a
Harriman Institute at Columbia
University which includes students from
the school
international Public Affairs PhD and
masters candidates from the Graduate
School of Arts and Sciences students
sometimes from the law school from the
journalism school from a school of
public health and many students learn
more from region and how different parts
of the region um who may or may not be a
more graceful I mean again we have this
problem these days she was an immigrant
who isn't you know who will stay who
will go back it's much harder to know my
personal favorite was a few years ago
when we had an oz Airy golden youth son
who had already had a degree from the
London School of Economics he was
collecting degrees and a rather
prominent Ukrainian human rights
activist and the class at the same time
and quite honestly the action was all
with the student fighting and and it was
part of what was to be studied so in
other words we more and more have come
to learn from our students you know
because we cannot possibly know
everything and they bring with them a
wealth of experience of growing up more
and more possible especially because
many of these students are older they do
have some Soviet experience although
trying to account for the Soviet
experience is becoming more and more as
it recedes in history is becoming harder
and harder um another topic i think
really should come up in this institute
is the growing role of human rights you
know the throwing interest of human
rights any economy as a whole and one of
the courses get we have put in at the
ham institute to respond to that is the
next course which is always a moving
target because human rights is of course
a living target itself human rights in
post-communist Eurasia which was
originally put in what by pink jupiler
who was one of the real fathers of human
rights in relation to dissident studies
had um this institution and then some
kind of Wilder courses that were not
specifically harriman courses but I
think I can speak to the kind of ways
we're trying to break you know
change the way we teach the region this
is a course that mark on Hagen tonight
taught originally and I and I more
recently taught with Richard wortman
called cities and civilization and
introduction to Eurasian studies and it
was it was an attempt to organize the
study of the regional cities which is a
very hot topic these days and we're
continuing to work on that that was an
undergraduate course so again unlike the
two preceding courses where we did have
people a lot of people from the region
in the course or emma grace and that was
a large part of what they were trying to
do this was mostly american-born
students um and last is the course that
was supposed to be taught this year or
last year but oh my goodness and I left
out them the course I actually must
meant to bring because I know one of you
is really interested in this topic I did
not bring my post new post learning
ality course but i'll talk a little bit
this but the same person i taught it
with the instructor list on socialist
post-socialist cities of Eurasia Charles
Armstrong was in Korea specialist he's a
historian I'll come back to talking
about that course a moment and i'll be
happy to make copies of that syllabus
available i was rushing a little bit
this is of course to follow our post
coloniality course where we wanted to
talk about east asian and eurasian and
former post-socialist cities really and
we hope to teach it if we are ever not
on leave at the same time we hope to
teach this course eventually this is a
working draft so I will all talk just
finally I'll take one more minute to
talk about the fact that we also taught
inspired by gayatri spivak is part of
the required well semi would not really
requires sort of except suggested
courses for the the certificate in
comparative livet literature and society
at columbia for graduate students of
course that was designed to look at East
Asia and Eurasia
areas excluded from post-colonial theory
and to discuss why they were excluded
and what we learned from looking at
post-colonial theory and dialogue with a
lot of different texts it was a fabulous
course mostly fabulous because of the
people who are in it and I think that's
my hook to Miami great topic there were
no Russian migr is in the course there
was one first generation Ukrainian
immigrant of course she is currently two
they were two of them were my Barnard
advisees one of them was a Russian
regional studies major she is currently
my Georgian instructor she actually got
her PhD at Columbia in ethnomusicology
focusing on Georgia this is an American
who has gone through Russia regional
studies and learn georgia violently to
marry George orgy always helps and and
the other one was a in her cohort a bar
nerd also she was our first Ukrainian
regional studies major and she is also
getting a PhD in ethnomusicology um at
Columbia and working on Ukrainian folk
folk music and rock music I'm so that
also points to a big change in our
students not just Americans were
learning different regions of the former
Soviet Union but who are going into
matically different disciplines F
theories ecology is not something that
we would have to really train themselves
to a certain extent there is nobody at
Columbia who knows anything about music
in that region except by disqus Potter
and he's not in effing musicology and
then we had one French a comparative
literature specialist who was wonderful
and was rage didn't join the francophone
colony world and then we had two chinese
students so when you talk about emma
grace you also get emigrates from other
areas in the world and so it gave us a
great comparative perspective um so you
know obviously I think what I'm pushing
here is the idea with it um as we look
at regional studies
I'm going to try and keep my migr lens
you're just a little bit out front you
know in the 21st century um to survive
it needs to be um tremendously flexible
in terms of the students serves of the
disc the way disciplines interrupt um
and in that sense the visionary project
that was started by but you know in the
war to solve problems and use different
disciplines coming together Marshall
something could be wonderfully eloquent
on the subject you know bringing people
from different points of views together
specifically to solve problems you know
to my mind and I'm a little bit utopian
myself it's one of the healthiest models
of real interdisciplinarity at a time in
the university when administrators pay
an awful lot of lip service student
disciplinary but don't really back it up
much of institutional support and so
places like the Herman Institute and
I'll throw some money in right now
before the financial crisis Herman had a
45 million dollar endowment that's a
nice chunk of change to be able to do
these kind of experiments with not
everybody has it wasn't from the
government it's private money and it is
basically under the control of the
faculty not the administration at call
me this is an almost utopian situation
so it gives I don't think anybody else I
mean I know that the davis center has
probably more money but it's more
entailed I mean we ours is very little
entailed we are also able to give a
large chunk of it in student fellowships
so it gives us a tremendous amount of
opportunity you know to play around and
do these kind of things which hopefully
will be the future but you know at a
time when the humanities are under
attack all over the place on time when
your occasional training is becoming
more and more more and more frightening
for front and foremost even at
University like this at a time when emma
grace in a sense you know almost
threatened language study because there
is that model out there that language
study is so expensive oh there's all
those emma grace who can do all that
work you know i mean we've got a lot
more people emigrate or we can go to the
region or you know we don't you know
it's not Emma greatest teachers but emma
grace is actually translators you know I
mean um and the more there are bilingual
speakers from the region or the more we
can see that we all know that beloved
formula of administrators let's just
send them off to study abroad for a
semester and that's their international
experience and we don't really need to
invest in a lot of languages you know I
mean so we've you know we we are facing
really serious that's an ironically
again the closer the more ability bitter
building to travel to the regions is
part of this rep and obviously I could
go on for a really long time but I'm
going to stop there